hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com so in this video guys
i'm gonna go through amc jimmy press
action but i also want to show you what
we're having on the global market on
triple two and on the
us 10 year yields because this is gonna
have a big impact on what can happen
next so let's get into it
[Music]
oh right yes i'm gonna start with amc
then i'm gonna talk about gme but guys
you need to stay until the end of this
video because i'm gonna show you what
we're having on triple two and on the
rates and you're gonna see that we are
in a situation i mean we are on the
verge of something bad or maybe
something good and i will show you what
you need to be looking at in order to
try to anticipate what can happen but
first
amc daily timeframe uh in my last video
guys i was telling you that we broke out
below the 17 level
which would very likely give us a move
towards the 16.3 area all right so this
is what happened yesterday we only moved
down by two percent 1.96 which is to me
a very i mean a decent move down
compared to what happened on the rest of
the market triple q was down 2.6 percent
i'm gonna analyze that very soon so amc
hold pretty well to me we can go have a
look on the hourly timeframe what
happened here so basically uh as very
often we opened the day bullish and then
we got rejected
around the 50 period moving average on
the hourly time frame it's not a strong
resistance but you know it just it got
rejected here we found support you can
see we had a little bit of excess below
this 16.3 level why 16.3 and not
something else as usual guys you look at
the past and here we had one two three
four reactions so this was the level
where we had buyers and we had a little
bit of access we finished the day with a
positive move uh as you can see the last
uh this is the close so on the close we
moved up by 1.3 which is uh quite
reassuring but once again guys uh what
will happen on mcn gme
will be related with what is going to
happen on the rest of the markets i'm
going to go through that very soon uh to
conclude on amc i'm going to be quick
guys because i want to talk about
everything in this video
so to conclude about amc 16.3 has hold
if it breaks guys i don't even have a
support below that it was my last
support the next support is around 13 at
that we go there i mean it's possible
but it doesn't look like uh we're gonna
go in that area for now especially given
what we had at the end of the day but
once again guys what is happening on the
rest of the market is a bit worrying me
so let's see what can happen here but we
need once again uh some strong volume to
happen guys on a bullish day for that
momentum to shift and for both to be
back in control if this happens i think
the confirmation of this once again
would be a breakout like we had here but
with volume increase as you can see here
i mean it's not a volume increase we add
here so for now we still looking for the
signal that will help us to go higher uh
now i had some questions regarding uh
this scenario uh is it still on the
table yes it is uh but once again it
won't happen if we are in the bear
market guys so i'm gonna show you what
uh we can look at to know if we're going
to enter a bear market or not and to be
honest guys the situation is not nice so
let's have a look at everything that we
have uh i'm done for g for amc now gme
so gme i told you guys the level 2 watch
was
142.3 uh 141.5 i have here i think it
was
here but then i moved it here i mean it
was not very clear as you can see uh on
thursday we closed the day right on this
support but i remember the support was
it a little bit higher then i moved it
lower because i wanted to match this red
candle so we closed here on thursday and
on friday we opened a little bit higher
and just like for amc and the rest of
the market we had a nice move up but i'm
very sure on low volume
as you can see
the open was here usually the open
candle is you know
quite big
and here it's a small volume
with i mean yeah basically the volume is
still low guys compared to what we had
here you can see we are still trending
on low volume uh we went here got
rejected at the under 20 hours uh simple
moving average and same thing then we
broke out here
no volume increase so once again those
signals are not very good quality but
it's still a breakout so it's still
likely that the move continues on the in
the same direction after breakout even
on low volume and yes so right now we
are a little bit in the middle of
nowhere guys we are between the 141.5
resistance now i'm gonna change the
color bam this is resistance this i
don't need it so we are likely guys to
go to the 130 level just like uh we were
likely for amc to go to the 16 level i
think that's 16 i mean
it's gonna hold i mean i don't know of
course but the reason that we don't have
any support below that makes me think
that
buyers are all located here right so
it's possible it breaks but to me this
last support being the last one is i
mean should be stronger right so uh
maybe a scenario that could make sense
is that gme comes back to 130
amc comes back maybe to 16 and then
maybe we're gonna have a move up if the
global market gives us some bounce as
well so here once again on the long term
uh we are still looking pretty good but
i mean only gme is looking good
everything else triple q and amc that
you know guys i like to analyze together
are not giving me good signals so here
gme as you can see still above the 61.8
percent fib ratio which is the ratio we
need to stay above for second waves to
keep the momentum bullish momentum
intact bullish momentum that has been
created in this first wave so for now it
is still intact but once again we have
weakness on amc and weakness on triple q
weakness on bitcoin as well i'm going to
show that
later as well guys in this video
so here we are likely to go to 130 level
and then we'll let's see what's going to
happen probably a bullish reaction but
can we go lower we can i'm here pretty
neutral guys in this area and once again
we need to go you know close uh to close
above 152 as i told you guys before this
was the range we were in and i told you
that once we get out of this range
probably we're gonna have a follow-up in
the same direction so
now the follow-up is probably gonna go
on the downside and then same thing guys
we need to close above 152 for bulls to
manage to take back control and get uh a
strong move up uh now let me come to
what is happening on triple two first i
want to show you the rates guys all
right this is the 10 year yield weekly
time frame you can have a look at that
guys keep an eye on that so rates are
not that easy to interpret in finance uh
usually when rates are going higher
it means that investors are dumping
bonds uh to
buy equity so we usually have positive
correlation between the yields and the
equity market which means whenever the
yields go up usually we have the equity
market going up but whenever we are in
an inflationary uh environment like we
are right now and you know
i mean a weak growth environment then
this correlation is inverted as you can
see guys since we started here to move
higher in december bam you can see
yields just doubled guys i mean it's a
lot yield doubling is not something we
see
often like that in such a short period
of time so we had yield doubling and in
the same time you guys know what
happened on global market december we
just you know move strongly lower so
right now the correlation between the
yields and the equity market is negative
another way to see that is just to
consider that yields are can be
considered by investors as the risk-free
rate
which is basically the expected return
of equity in the long term so that's why
it's a proxy for a lot of assets it's
also a proxy for growth and here the way
you can see that is that the equity
market needs to grow by more than 2.9
every year for the next 10 years and
it's harder to do whenever this yield is
higher so right now the yields are
putting pressure on the equity when the
yields are higher it means that it's
going to be tougher for the equity
market to beat the yield you know the
risk-free rate so it's another way to
see that
and if you don't want to think too much
about that just you know look at the
correlation you can see the question is
negative right now and guys i don't like
what i see what i'm seeing here i've
been monitoring this field for the past
uh you know a few months and here guys
we have this trend line as you can see
guys since 81
you know
1981 guys it's a 40 years
trend that we are back about to break
guys so what does it mean guys not good
if we and here look we have we having
the breakout i don't have volume here so
i cannot apply the usual methods uh but
what i can tell you is that we having
for the first time a breakout of the
10-year yield above this level my
friends working at goldman sachs in
asset management told me that
they are fine you know because they
advise the investors what to do with the
money right we are talking about big
money and they told me that um they are
fine with the yield going to three
percent and that above three percent
is going to be a bit dangerous area
and the advice today investors would be
like stay away from equity we are in a
risk of uh mode so does break out 2.9
right so they said three so they're fine
but i can tell you guys that the three
level they had
is probably coming from i don't know
where it's coming from but
it's pretty much in line with my trend
line here and this breakout guys is not
good because if we keep
going higher after this breakout so
maybe re-test go higher guys this would
be a big big crisis all right so i don't
want this to happen the good thing i'm
seeing here guys uh if i do some
technical analysis with yields which one
once again i don't know if it's really
relevant but i mean this trend line is
pretty clean right so whenever you have
a clean trend line it means that traders
use it right so i'm afraid this breakout
is not good news and the only good thing
i see is that uh for those who followed
my course you guys know that for
breakout to be good quality we like to
have a consideration before a breakup
that happens without consideration is
usually attacked by bears so hopefully
bears are going to attack the shields
and get it back to a lower level but
once again this is related as you guys
know to inflation and
this is happening after paul's speech
that was very hawkish and
this move above this trend line means
that a lot of investors are actually
pricing the fact that we're going to
have even more hawkishness in this
market because of inflation that is
going to stay longer than expected and
all the bad things with wall with growth
that is going to be weaker you know all
of that is here uh can be read in those
yields so once again keep an eye on that
guys if you see deals above three
that's not good so triple q guys so i
sent an alert in my discord guys once
again i can share it here with you so
basically i said that after the breakout
below 338 as you guys know i personally
took a long position i made a little bit
of profits because i i stopped my
position at 339.5
live with you yesterday and here i'm
back to my short position so now i made
uh decent money here on the move down
and actually made money overall on my
portfolio because amc and gme moves were
very small compared to triple q so this
strong move down on triple q helped me
to be positive i didn't make big money a
few hundred dollars but it's still good
for me now i know that if the market
keeps dropping i'm making money so i'm
fine i mean my position is under control
and here my view was that if we break
out below 338 we're gonna have a
follow-up on the downside which we had
yesterday i sent an alert with a selling
order at 338 for those who were not
having a short position unfortunately
we didn't even reach that level on the
retest so maybe we will but now i think
we first gonna go here maybe then
rebound and then go lower i gave you my
probabilities guys this is of course a
very rough estimation that i just do you
know like that i think there is 30
chance that we have a strong move down
to the 280 area a 50 chance that we just
move sideways so the sideways scenario
would be good for mcn gme uh given the
fact that here uh by moving two point
six percent amc and gm we hold pretty
well so if you if we move lower by again
two three percent they will probably
stay around the same level and then if
you have the strong rebound even in the
sideways scenario we could have some
nice moves on amc but if we go here if
this is the scenario that uh takes the
lead and we are bearish guys and we go
lower for the next two three months guys
it won't be good for mcn gme and for
bitcoin and from
every uh speculative asset so this is
unfortunately a scenario that is on the
table that is going to be correlated
what is going to happen with the yields
so bam bam bam yeah john the my discord
guys if you want to have more
information link in the description of
this video of course what else can i
tell you so here yeah i'm gonna be a
seller if we get back in this area guys
between three three eight and 350 i'm
going to increase my uh shock position
and to conclude i wanted to show you now
i'm not gonna have time yeah maybe i
have a little bit of time so i market
guys oil market for now i have a lot of
questions about that you guys know that
i'm bullish here uh so just i have a lot
of questions like about some stocks that
i was pushing where i made personally
good money but for those who entered
maybe a bit later now you know that
they're scared that they dump and the
levels to watch for all of this energy
stocks is of course on the old market
and it's the 100 level right above 100
we're good for now we this is still a
bullish setup for me and the scenario
that we go here which is going to be
very bearish for the market by the way
very bullish for the yields
not good for amc and jme but
unfortunately this is the scenario i'm
having on oil and if we go here to this
area what i mean is that we are likely
to do to make this move in the coming
months uh as long as we stay above 100
but there is also a bearish scenario
where here we just drop so
this would be actually positive for the
market so let's find out guys but above
100 we are bullish on energy stocks
that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys